[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Siebers guten
Abend ihnen wir sind an einem
Scheidepunkt der Geschichte hat Japans
Regierungschef heute gesagt und viel
höher kann man das Treffen der großen
westlichen Staaten ja auch nicht mehr
hängen
g7-gipfel in Japan eine härtere Gangart
im Umgang mit Russland und China wollen
die sieben beschließen ob das wirklich
geschehen ob das wirklich geschlossen
klappt das ist alles andere als sicher
der Ort an dem sich alle treffen könnte
nicht zum wohlträchtiger sein Hiroshima
wo geschätzt 140.000 Menschen starben
beim ersten Einsatz von Atombomben in
der Kriegsgeschichte und gemeinsam mit
einer kasaki 3 Tage später auch den
bislang einzigen miriam steineimer ist
in Hiroshima
das sind die Worte die sich hinaus aber
mit chicos Gedächtnis eingebrannt haben
ist hier jemand auf Japanisch gesprochen
mit einem ausländischen Akzent
ich dachte Japan sei schon besiegt und
die amerikanischen Soldaten würden
kommen um mich zu holen
es sind ihre Erinnerungen an den
sechsten august 1945 als
US-amerikanische Streitkräfte die
Atombombe little boy über Hiroshima
abwerfen
aber Yumi will die Erinnerung ihrer
Mutter erhalten
wir saßen bei einer Tasse Tee und mein
Schwager erzählte eine witzige
Geschichte wir brachen ein lautes
Gelächter aus in dem Moment gab es
draußen einen hellen Blitz und eine
Explosion wir wurden durch die Luft
geschleudert und das Haus stürzte ein
und begräbt sie unter sich mit ihrer
Mutter und ihrer Schwester der Schwager
ist direkt tot
dass die Stimme mit dem ausländischen
Akzent keinem Amerikaner gehörte fand
die Familie nach vielen Jahren heraus
es war ein deutscher Priester der die
damals 15-Jährige aus den Trümmern zog
sie gibt nicht gerne Interviews für das
deutsche Fernsehen macht sie eine
Ausnahme
Hiroshima ist die Stadt der Atombombe
die Spuren ihrer Zerstörung sind die
Kulisse für das Gipfeltreffen sie
erinnern die Staats- und Regierungschefs
die heute hier ankommen an ihre
Verantwortung
die nukleare Katastrophe die hier erlebt
worden es ist eine Mahnung an uns alle
dass wir dafür Sorge tragen müssen dass
es niemals zum Einsatz von Atomwaffen
kommt
die Familie des japanischen premiers
kishida stammt aus Hiroshima als
Gastgeschenk kommt sein britischer
Kollege in Socken des lokalen Baseball
Teams
für den amerikanischen Präsidenten ist
es sehr viel schwieriger ausgerechnet an
diesem historischen Ort zu treffen heute
stehen sie demonstrativ zusammen für die
Ukraine gegen Russland
dass die Mächtigen der Welt auch das
Friedensmuseum in ihrer Heimatstadt
besichtigen werden findet aber Yumi gut
die Leute wissen nicht genug über den
Atombombenabwurf aber sie wollen
nukleare Waffen einsetzen oder drohen
anderen Ländern damit wir wollen nie
wieder Hiroshima
sie zeigt uns die Nachfahren ihrer
Mutter zwei Töchter fünf Enkelinnen 11
Uhr Enkel sie alle gibt es nur weil es
aber mit Chico die Atombombe überlebte
als einzige ihrer Familie
wie es sich für Sie anfühlt dass ihr
Land gemeinsam mit den USA am
gipfeltisch sitzt sie hasse weder
Amerika noch die Amerikaner was sie
hasse sei Krieg
dann gucken wir jetzt auf die politische
Agenda des Treffens zusammen mit Elmar
twissen live in Hiroshima guten Abend
Elmar klare Kante gegenüber Russland
wollen die G7 zeigen was ist denn da
konkret vom Gipfel zu erwarten
ja nennen wir es mal die Kunst des
Machbaren bei dem Versuch die
Schlupflöcher bei den Sanktionen gegen
Russland irgendwie zu schließen ein
Beispiel der Diamantenhandel Russland
verdient jährlich Milliarden als
weltgrößter Lieferant von Rohdiamanten
wenn man die echtet wenn man diesen
Handel unterbindet und das wollen die G7
dann wäre das sicherlich ein starkes
Signal ein noch stärkeres Signal wäre es
wenn man gegen Unternehmen und
Regierungen Sanktionen verhängt die
weiteren an Russland liefern die Putin
dann in seinem Antrieb Angriffskrieg
verwenden kann da wieder amerikanische
Präsidentin in den nächsten Tagen ein
Sanktionspaket vorlegen ob die anderen
mitmachen auch die Europäer das ist
völlig offen denn wenn man das macht
dann trifft es sicherlich nicht nur
starten wie Iran und Nordkorea sondern
vielleicht auch starten wie Südafrika
oder eben und ganz bestimmt eigentlich
China und dafür möchten manche eben das
aus China Gegenmaßnahmen drohen und da
sind wir immer bereits beim Verhältnis
zu China das ist ja ein Balance
da kommen von den G7 ganz
unterschiedliche Ansagen auf was wird es
dann am Ende hinauslaufen
ich glaube auch hier geht es wieder um
das Machbare und da gibt es keinen der
im Grunde eine total Abkopplung von
China will selbst die USA haben wir im
vergangenen Jahr ihren Handel mit China
noch einmal ausgebaut das Zauberwort
hier ist die Wrestling das heißt also
die Abhängigkeit von China ein Stück
weit verringern indem man sich mehr
andere Handelspartner sucht zum Beispiel
Schwellen und Entwicklungsländer in die
will man Billionen Investitionen tätigen
auch um zu erreichen dass sie eben
diesen elitären Club der G7 im Grunde
genommen nicht mehr so sehen dass er sie
im Stich gelassen hat dahinter steckt
natürlich eine große Hoffnung man will
dass der globale Süden Brasilien Indien
Indonesien und andere sind ja als Gäste
hier mit eingeladen dass diese Länder
eben nicht die autoritären Regime in
Moskau und Peking weiter als die
verlässlicheren Partner ansehen aber
damit das geschieht da Bedarf ist
natürlich nicht nur guter Worte sondern
es müssen dann auch Taten folgen wir
sind gespannt auf diese Taten in den
nächsten Tagen für heute Abend
herzlichen Dank Matthi wir sind live aus
dem Regen von Hiroshima
Aufbruch und scheitern wir gedenken
heute beidem denn genau vor 175 Jahren
trat das erste gesamtdeutsch gewählte
Parlament zusammen in der Frankfurter
Paulskirche um über eine freiheitliche
Verfassung zu entscheiden die Verfassung
trat nie in Kraft zur Demokratie wurde
Deutschland erst 1919 mit der Weimarer
Republik der Tag heute in Frankfurt in
der Paulskirche an historischem Ort ist
dann auch beides sowohl Plädoyer für
demokratische Prozesse als auch Mahnung
dass diese keine Selbstverständlichkeit
sind Peter Theisen berichtet
es ist der 18 mai 1848 tausende
Frankfurter sind zur Paulskirche
gekommen um den Abgeordneten der ersten
deutschen Nationalversammlung zu
zujubeln es herrscht Aufbruchstimmung in
Deutschland Hoffnung auf Demokratie
Einheit und Freiheit heute haben wir sie
die Demokratie dass sie aber nicht
selbstverständlich ist daran soll er
erinnert werden 175 Jahre danach der
Bundespräsident mahnt wer heute
Parlamente verhöhnt ständig von dem
System von Gleichschaltung und
Meinungsdiktatur spricht der verhöhnt in
Wahrheit diejenigen die für Freiheit und
Demokratie gekämpft haben der symbolort
Paulskirche als erstes historisches
Gebäude in Frankfurt wurde sie nach den
Zerstörungen des Krieges wieder
aufgebaut nach der Naziherrschaft als
einer der wichtigsten Erinnerungsorte
der deutschen Demokratie doch der Neubau
von 1948 ist in die Jahre gekommen und
soll gründlich saniert werden und ganz
in der Nähe sobald ein Haus der
Demokratie entstehen dass auf die große
Bedeutung der Paulskirche hinweist und
zum Nachdenken und Diskutieren über
Demokratie einladen soll das Haus der
Demokratie würde gewissermaßen den
Brückenschlag in die Gegenwart
hinbekommen müssen und von dort aus
verschiedene Zielgruppen adressieren
Jugendliche selbstverständlich aber ich
denke auch an Gäste aus dem Ausland in
denen vielleicht keine Demokratie
herrscht das ist als Ergänzung geplant
zur Paulskirche als Stärkung dessen was
1848 verwandelt und eine Verwandlung in
die Zukunft als ein öffentlicher ein
strahlender Ort vor allem über das wo
dieses Hauses der Demokratie wird in
Frankfurt noch heftig gestritten aber
die Debatte gehört ja zur Demokratie wie
die Besucher in diesen Tagen anschaulich
erfahren können in einer Zeitreise zur
ersten deutschen Nationalversammlung
Historiker haben die Protokolle von
damals aufgearbeitet bitte stimmen Sie
über diese Frage ab die Geschichte
verpflichtet für die Neugestaltung der
Paulskirche mit einem Haus der
Demokratie fordert der Bundespräsident
einen nationale Kraftanstrengung die
Paulskirche lassen sich so sagen ist
wirklich ein Schatz nationaler Bedeutung
den wir alle miteinander gemeinsam zum
Glänzen bringen sollten der
demokratische Aufbruch von 1848
scheiterte am Ende Freiheit und
Demokratie sind nie selbstverständlich
und müssen immer wieder neu errungen und
verteidigt werden das ist die Botschaft
der Paulskirche heute
zwischen Kontroverse und Kompromiss die
Zutaten einer lebendigen Demokratie sind
heute genauso essentiell und
gleichzeitig umstritten wie vor 175
Jahren die Welt steht vor existenziellen
Herausforderungen aber was heißt das für
uns wie viele Regeln wie viele Verbote
wie viel Diskussionen wollen können
müssen wir uns leisten es ist ein guter
Tag heute um darüber nachzudenken
Christian von Rechenberg hat das getan
Gebäude Energiegesetz Heizung tauschen
keine Widerrede war das wieder so ein
Beispiel dass wir nur noch an Mauern
prallen heizen fliegen alles falsch
alles verboten KSG GEG überall
Verordnungen muss das sein geht's nicht
anders
ich glaube dass wir in einer
Gesellschaft leben in der Menschen
erwarten dass Dinge die wirklich wichtig
sind essentiell wichtig sind
insbesondere wenn es um Leben und Tod
geht dass es dann auch die
entsprechenden Regelungen und Gesetze
gibt es geht nicht ohne Regeln beim
Klimaschutz wir sind perfekte Verdränger
und wir haben es gerne sehr bequem und
wenn dann mal so ein verregneter april
kommt ja dann denken die Menschen ja
doch wir haben noch Zeit vernünftiges
Verhalten kommt nicht von selbst wie war
das mit dem Rauchverbot oder beim
Sicherheitsgurt wir müssen zum Glück
gezwungen werden
Dezernent Michael kopatz für den Marburg
aus Autofahrern Rad und Busfahrer machen
alle wollen weniger Autos doch keiner
steigt freiwillig um also nimmt er den
Autos den Platz weg jetzt haben wir
schon erste Radwege angelegt wo man
denkt toll das gefällt mir gut und dann
wenn man solche Strukturen ändert wenn
man das Radfahren so fördert dann ändern
Menschen ihre Routine gut anfühlen soll
es sich das gewünschte Verhalten
momentan fühlen sich viele gegängelt
also kannst ja auch nicht funktionieren
in einer freien Gesellschaft oder die
Menschen müssen selber entscheiden
können an welcher Stelle sie CO2
einsparen wie sie die Klimaziele
Einhalten der Staat hat die Aufgabe
Rahmenbedingungen zu schaffen und das
ist die einzige Aufgabe des Staates die
Aufgabe des Staates ist nicht dafür zu
sorgen dass einzelne Dinge geregelt
werden die Leuten Vorschriften oder
Vorgaben gemacht werden denn
Ordnungsrecht kann er ja gar nicht alle
Lebensbereiche Regeln und das sei dessen
schwächer
ich bin ein großer Fan vom Liberalismus
und selber ein sehr freiheitlichen neuen
Mensch aber ich weiß ganz genau dass sie
Fortschritte die wir beim Klimaschutz in
den letzten 20 Jahren erreicht haben nur
kam durch Gesetze und Rahmenbedingungen
so weit zu Streit aber das Klima wartet
nicht es heizt uns ein es trocknet uns
aus überschwemmt uns allein es bringt
uns nicht zum Handeln
nun ich glaube schon dass tatsächlich
Menschen nur dann handeln wenn sie
letzten Endes auch ein Mehrwert darin
sehen das heißt Sie müssen profitieren
und genau das ist im Moment jedenfalls
bei der Klima Gesetzgebung nicht der
Fall Geld als Lockstoff das passt in
unser System das strukturell auf
Wachstum setzt sagt der Soziologe doch
der Motor des Wohlstands Treiber auch
die Klimakrise an und er jetzt wissen
wir zwar dass es nicht so gut ist für
die Umwelt aber er es kommt zu einem
Dauerkonflikt zwischen dem was uns gut
und verheißungsvoll erscheint und dem
was uns ökologisch vernünftig erscheint
und da ist es tatsächlich so dass das
ökologisch vernünftige meistens in
kürzeren zieht Gesetze fühlen sich an
die Gänge gelungen saubere Energie wie
Belastung das System dreht sich im Kreis
was nun gibt es denn keinen
Ausweg
Moral kommt immer also oben da
Zeigefinger du darfst nicht obwohl du
willst und ich glaube was diese
Gesellschaft braucht ist eine ein neues
Nachdenken darüber was wollen wir
eigentlich unter welchen Bedingungen
gelingt unser Leben und dann werden wir
sehen wir können auch nicht nur ein
gutes Leben haben wenn es auch im
Einklang mit der Natur um uns herum
geführt wird es wäre die große ethische
Debatte der Versuch klimagerechtes
Verhalten zum coolen Trend zu machen am
Ende geht es vielleicht nicht nur über
die und Verbote sondern auch über das
Gefühl das gefühlte Mauern überwindet
das öffentliche und gemeinsame Suche
nach dem richtigen Weg unverzichtbar und
schwierig zugleich Anna du guckst jetzt
auf ein großes Streit Thema dieser Tage
und bleibt damit quasi beim Thema
Wirtschaft
sstand konzipierte heizungsgesetz der
wirtschaftspolitische Sprecher der FDP
Hupen hält den bisherigen Zeitplan für
nicht mehr haltbar das ziel müsse sein
die Menschen bei diesem schwierigen
Gesetz mitzunehmen die Grünen sprachen
dagegen von einer Verzögerungstaktik und
forderten Verlässlichkeit auch die SPD
sieht keinen Grund zu verschieben
eigentlich soll das Vorhaben bis Anfang
Juli beschlossen werden
das Bundeswirtschaftsministerium hat
Vorwürfe gegen einen weiteren
Staatssekretär der Behörde
zurückgewiesen und dessen
Unternehmensbeteiligungen offengelegt
dem für Start-ups zuständigen Udo
Philipp war ein möglicher
Interessenskonflikt vorgeworfen worden
da er privat in mehrere Firmen
investiert hatte das
Wirtschaftsministerium erklärte nun man
habe bereits vorsorglich sichergestellt
dass Philipp keine entscheidendungen
treffe von denen eines dieser
Unternehmen profitieren könnte in der
Ukraine hat es in der vergangenen Nacht
erneut zahlreiche Luftangriffe auf Kiew
und andere Regionen gegeben laut
ukrainischen Angaben wurden dabei 29 von
30 Marschflugkörpern abgeschlossen in
Kiew kam es zu Explosionen und
Trümmerteile lösten einen Brand aus in
der Hafenstadt Odessa wurde bei dem
Angriff auf ein Industriegelände ein
Mensch getötet aus der heftig umkämpften
Stadt bachmut meldet die Ukraine
Geländegewinn e im Norden und Süden
um den Jerusalem Tag zu feiern sind am
Abend rund 20.000 nationalistische
Israelis mit Flaggen durch Jerusalem
gezogen der Marsch wurde von mir als
2.500 Polizisten begleitet er führte
auch durch muslimische Teile der
Altstadt was Palästinenser als extreme
Provokation sehen vereinzelt kam es zu
Auseinandersetzungen am Jerusalem Tag
feiert Israel die Eroberung Ost
Jerusalems in sechs Tage Krieg von 1967
kennst du das Land wo die Zitronen
blühen im dunklen Laub die goldorangen
glühen ein sanfter Wind vom blauen
Himmel weht die Myrte still und hoch der
Lorbeer steht seit Goethes Zeiten diese
Sehnsucht nach Italien wird uns auch das
Auswärtige Amt nicht nehmen der warnende
deutsche Sicherheitshinweis für Italien
heute ist im Grunde ein Widerspruch in
sich und dennoch Realität Italien kämpft
mit verheerenden Überschwemmungen
mindestens 13 Menschen sind bereits
gestorben das ist das Ende der Welt sagt
ein lokalbürgermeister in der besonders
getroffenen Emilia Romania Sünder
braucht jetzt mit mehr
hier im Logo steht nach den extremen
Regenfällen das Wasser noch immer fast
einen halben Meter hoch in den Straßen
innerhalb von knapp zwei Tagen viel an
manchen Stellen so viel Regen wie
normalerweise in einem halben Jahr danke
von Logo erreichen würde aber viele
Dörfer in der Region befinden sich in
der gleichen Situation so viele
Arbeitsplätze so viele Früchte
lebenslange Arbeit die sich alle in
Rauch aufgelöst haben und den Bach
hinunter gegangen sind aber wir krempeln
die Ärmel hoch und fangen wieder an zu
kämpfen
Optiker in Logo wie andere Anwohner
ärgert er sich über schlechtes
Krisenmanagement und darüber dass die
Stadt nicht vorbereitet war
am Anfang war da nicht viel Wasser aber
dann ist es immer weiter gestiegen es
hat sich von draußen von dort drüben in
die Ladenpassage ergossen dahin wo wir
jetzt stehen
und diese Abläufe sind vollkommen dicht
es fließt nichts mehr ab inzwischen ist
in Logo das Militär eingetroffen um der
Bevölkerung zu helfen rettungskräfte
versuchen anderen Orts noch immer Städte
und Dörfer zu erreichen die nach den
Überschwemmungen abgeschnitten sind vom
Straßen Strom und Handynetz einige
abgelegene Dörfer in der Region Emilia
Romania sind völlig isoliert weil er
Rutsche die Straßen und passierbar
gemacht haben
das habe ich noch nie gesehen es ist das
erste Mal in 30 Jahren ist das erste Mal
dass wir mit einem solchen Ereignis
konfrontiert werden
mehr als 10.000 Menschen mussten ihre
Häuser in der Region verlassen die die
sich nicht in höhere Stockwerke flüchten
konnten wurden mit Hubschraubern von
Dächern gerettet andere mit
Schlauchbooten des Katastrophenschutzes
in Sicherheit gebracht nun kehren
etliche Bewohner in ihre Häuser zurück
beginnen mit den Aufräumarbeiten wie
hier in feinzer wo auch noch Teile der
Stadt unter Wasser stehen
es geschah alles ganz plötzlich ich habe
ein vier Monate altes Baby wir hätten
nicht gedacht dass so etwas passieren
könnte wir waren nicht organisiert
gestern Abend musste ich zurück in die
Wohnung kommen um Windeln und andere
Dinge zu holen und das Wasser kam bis
hierher
der regionalpräsident spricht von
Schäden in Milliardenhöhe fordert
schnelle Hilfe von der Regierung die
nächsten Niederschläge sind bereits
angekündigt
erst extreme Trockenheit dann extremer
Regen ein extrem Ereignis nach dem
anderen exakt das sagen die Experten ist
nicht mehr Wetter das ist Klima in der
Krise
Anna du machst jetzt weiter mit der
Wirtschaft ja und zwar mit einem Blick
Richtung USA denn dort droht bereits
Anfang Juni ein Zahlungsausfall wenn es
US-Präsident beiden nicht gelingt sich
mit den Republikanern im Kongress auf
eine Anhebung der Schulden Obergrenze zu
einigen Valerie Haller die Zeit drängt
und jetzt scheint zumindest etwas
Bewegung in die Sache zu kommen ja
richtig einen Durchbruch ist es zwar
noch nicht aber nach einem Krisentreffen
zwischen Präsident beiden und seinem
republikanischen Kontrahenten mccasi
haben sich beide zuversichtlich gezeigt
dass sich bald eine Lösung finden wird
man sei sich einig dass ein
Zahlungsausfall schlicht keine Option
sei sagt meiden ein Schreckenszenario
entsprechend groß die Hoffnung der DAX
schafft sogar den Sprung über die 16.000
Streit über die Anhebung der Schulden
Obergrenze die kommt ja in den USA
häufiger vor nur dieses mal sind die
Fronten extrem verhärtet und die Zeit
für einen Kompromiss ziemlich knapp
welche Auswirkungen hätte ein
Zahlungsausfall denn ganz konkret
verheerende Folgen könnte ein
staatsbankrat haben für die USA weil die
Regierung ja nicht mehr verlässlich ihre
Rechnungen bezahlen kann keine
Sozialversicherung keine
Krankenversicherung keine Pensionen die
USA würden mit ausstehenden Krediten in
Verzug geraten Rating-Agenturen könnten
die Kreditwürdigkeit herunterstufen
Zinsen dürften dann in die Höhe
schnellen ein Zahlungsausfall hätte aber
auch globale folgen ein börsenbeben und
möglicherweise eine weltweite Rezession
das ganze Finanzsystem ist auf der
Gewissheit aufgebaut die USA zahlen ihre
Rechnungen immer wäre das nicht mehr der
Fall wäre der Vertrauensverlust der
Finanzmärkte immens vielen Dank Valerie
für diese Einordnungen
im Handwerk sind knapp 40.000
Ausbildungsplätze nicht besetzt das
erklärte der Präsident des
Zentralverbands des deutschen Handwerks
Dietrich in der Rheinischen Post
besonders betroffen sein die Bereiche
Heizung Sanitär Klima
Elektroinstallation und bau ein Problem
sei dass der Übergang von der Schule in
die Ausbildung nicht mehr richtig
funktioniere zudem müsse mehr für die
Vereinbarkeit von Beruf und Familie
getan werden damit mehr Frauen in
Vollzeit arbeiten könnten sagte Dietrich
und eine Meldung vom Sport da hatten
heute die Fußballerinnen des VfL
Wolfsburg allen Grund zum Feiern zum
zehnten Mal gewannen sie den DFB-Pokal
und besiegten den SC Freiburg mit vier
zu eins
Konfetti und der 9 Pokalsieg
nacheinander für die Wolfsburgerinnen
nach einer starken und abgeklärten
Leistung schon in der vierten Minute
eröffnet ein Freiburger Eigentor die
Partie Torhüterin Lambert kann den Ball
zwar abwehren schießt aber die eigene
Spielerin Lisa Karl an 1:0 für Wolfsburg
der VfL war Ton angeben aber Freiburg
mit der Chance in der 42 Minute es folgt
eine Ecke und der Ausgleich durch Janina
Minke das 1:1 die Freiburgerinnen nach
der Halbzeit jetzt angriffslustiger doch
ein Konter Leute den Wolfsburger Sieg
ein Eva pior mit dem Pfosten und Rebecca
Blomquist mit der Führung 58 Minuten das
3:1 fällt dann nach Ecke Kapitän in
Alexandra Popp mit Köpfchen sie steht
mal wieder Gold richtig bleibt der sie
Treffer nach diesem Handelfmeter Dominik
Jansen mit den vier zu eins entstand das
war's die Wolfsburgerinnen werden von
knapp 45.000 Zuschauern gefeiert
ausverkauften Kölner Stadion
er war schauspielikone und wurde einst
zum schönsten Mann der Welt erklärt der
österreichische Schauspieler Helmut
Berger ist tot er starb im Alter von 78
Jahren seine Rolle in lukino Viscontis
Film die verdammten machten die
weltberühmt der italienische Regisseur
hatte Berge entdeckt und wurde zu seinem
Lebensgefährten als der Wahnsinnige
Bayernkönig Ludwig spielte Berger die
Rolle seines Lebens später machte er
dann vor allem Schlagzeilen abseits des
Kinos sein Agentur zitiert ihn heute mit
den Worten general ich bereue nichts
die Filmwelt trauert und die Show muss
gleichzeitig weitergehen in kann wo
Helmut Berger zuletzt noch mal 2014 auf
dem roten Teppich groß gefeiert wurde
hat heute ein Abenteurer Weltpremiere
Indiana Jones und das Rad des Schicksals
der fünfte Teil mehr als 15 Jahre nach
dem vierten Teil Harrison Ford ist
mittlerweile 80 aber digitale Effekte
haben ihn auf der Leinwand deutlich
verjüngt der Film Komponist John
Williams selbst 91 sagt für mich ist
Harrison Ford ein Teenager das kann also
noch länger so weitergehen wenn der Film
an der Kasse gut läuft denn kann ist
Leben Kunst und Glamour eben immer auch
Commerz wie Thomas Walter
Wim wenn das und Anselm Kiefer auf dem
roten Teppichen kann Pedro almodora mit
seinen Schauspielern Johnny Depp
inmitten seiner filmbesetzung sie alle
können wohl den Satz unterschreiben mit
dem Depp die Anwesenheit begründet
wir sind alle hier weil wir einen Film
gemacht haben und nicht weil wir ein
Produkt verkaufen wollen
doch der Grad zwischen Kunst und Verkauf
ist schmal in kann wenn das Festival
Michael Douglas eine ehrenpalme gibt für
sein Lebenswerk haben beide etwas davon
Douglas bekommt Anerkennung kann
prominenten klar
Goldene Palme für das Lebenswerk
bedeutet mir eine Menge es gibt hunderte
Filmfestivals auf der Welt aber das kann
Festival ist einzigartig Karl ich habe
hier eine persönliche Verbindung und
mein Vater hatte die auch seine Frau war
PR-Frau des Festivals hier ist
patriculation sind
die gültige Währung auf der Rückseite
des Festival Gebäudes findet sich der
Maschinenraum kunst ist schön muss aber
auch Geld verdienen 4000 Filme suchen
hier ihre Kunden
das ist ein Film der ein sehr
unterschiedliches Publikum erreichen
kann junge Menschen und Familien
das entspricht meinen Vorstellungen
diesen Film will ich mir ansehen
Pyramid ist einer der großen
französischen Verleiher der Wettbewerb
um goldene Palmen und goldene Kunden
geht Hand in Hand
wir haben dieses Jahr sechs Filmen kann
in unterschiedlichen Sektionen wir
können hier Käufern exklusiv die Filme
unter sehr guten Bedingungen zeigen sie
müssen nicht anstehen finden leicht
einen Platz und sehen die Filme manchmal
sogar vor der offiziellen Aufführung die
Position
ist ein deutscher Nachwuchs Regisseur er
sucht Geld für seine nächsten Film
Klinken putzen für ein paar Millionen
Euro
ich glaube für uns und für dieses
Projekt in dieser sehr frühen Phase ist
das interessanteste hier wirklich
allerlei Kontakte und Input zu kriegen
wie man den Pitch an sich besser machen
kann wie man die das ganze Projekt
aufladen kann von den kleinen bis zu den
ganz großen alle sind da weil alle da
sind kann Filmfest und der Markt dazu
ist eigentlich ja der wichtigste Event
vom ganzen Jahr für uns für die Branche
so prägt kann den Massengeschmack weit
über die französische Cote d'Azur hinaus
fehlt noch der Blick auf die
Wetteraussichten morgen scheint an der
Nordsee die Sonne ansonsten ist es meist
heiter später wolkig in den Alpen sind
am Nachmittag einzelne Schauer möglich
die Temperatur steigt auf 14 bis 21 Grad
der Samstag wird freundlich nur im
Südosten entwickeln sich einzelne
Schauer am Sonntag regnet es häufiger am
Montag gibt es im Westen kräftige
Gewitter weil dann 21 bis 30 Grad
von uns allen hier Danke fürs Interesse
für den Moment gleich nach uns können
Sie den Kollegen Markus Lanz begleiten
auf einer Reise in ein wirklich
aufregendes Land
und wir sehen uns noch mal später wieder
wenn Sie mögen so heute Express gegen
0:30 Uhr auf jeden Fall bis morgen in
allen einen angenehmer
[Musik]